on this episode of dudy I would be in
the tub like taking a bath he would come
in and just pour beer on my head let him
squeeze my
[Music]
boobies holes are
spooky look at you you're an orange and
black it's like it's Halloween
hallowe I can't hear you because the
song I can hear
you okay Chad on today of all days let's
have a tremendous show let's have a
fantastic show it's Halloween you look
great welcome to dudy welcome all it's a
dudul day I am Will Sasso I am death and
this is dudy the first podcast in the
history of humanity created by
controlled by processed by engineered by
an artificial intelligence that will and
I have given access to all of our person
personal data and it manufactures this
show kind of tailor made to our
sensibilities mhm isn't it something
it's really something you know it does
all that stuff and our pal d uh you know
spins the Wheels of Steel isn't it
something isn't it something and uh but
then you know you're going to need a
couple of dudes two dudes [__]
around and that's uh and that's you know
and that's us because that's what a
podcast is and then our pod show we like
to we like to do the Pod show so we're
going to have to be here for that hey uh
with us as always
is he's he's says what do you want what
are you what are you doing for for
Halloween you going to do anything no no
I'm a dog please don't put a stupid
outfit on me I don't want to do and it's
like I know that I know because you're
just a little baby boy you're not going
to dress him up no [__] that I hate it
when people dress up look at how C he's
going as the cutest little doggy in the
world World maybe just a little bow tie
or something oh that would be nice with
a ghost on or some pumpkins yeah he has
a bow tie he wears a special bow tie for
special times what do you want to go
back in your binky bunker yeah I'm just
going to go eat a candy in my Binky
bunker oh he's so sweet oh he's such a
sweet boy no he wouldn't want to be in a
[__] hat or a bow tie the whole time
yeah I really hate it when people dress
their dogs up screw you welcome to the
79th precious episode of dudy get ready
to toast your ghosts and fool your
ghouls because it's Halloween all
Hallow's Eve devil's night that special
time once a year when the old gods arise
from their Slumber to renew their pact
with a thousand face demon to hold off
their March against humanity until the
year
2027 why oh my God you boys look so cute
in your little costumes I absolutely
love it I hate to admit it but I think I
just got duded by your goddamn
cuteness look at that that's nice yeah
you do look good dude so do you so to
you if you're only listening right now
you're going to have to head over to
youtube.com and when you do subscribe
Chad's dressed up as the Grim Reaper uh
I or you know death as it were or just
Chad and uh I am fat Ken yeah but I'm
Ken quite the doo that was a chilling
thing that dudy said in the beginning
that Halloween is when the old gods make
a deal with the devil or something to
not march on Humanity until the year
2027 see I don't even know what what
Halloween is necessarily it's an old
pagan holiday but that that's a that's a
you know that's a good as good a guess
as any yeah I I guess so I mean 2027 is
pretty close though it's always 2027 why
I don't anyway something D's got
something cooking I guess guys did you
see BRZ fencil gave the commencement
speech at the UCLA School of podcast
criticism last week I just want to play
a little part of it if you don't mind I
think you're going to like it I can't
wait you're all about to graduate with
degrees in podcast criticism now what
right right how do you turn the four
years you spent listening to podcasts
and writing essays about them into a job
I'll let you know when I figure it out
just a little podcast humor for you
there but in all seriousness everybody
listens to podcast and everybody has
their opinions but not everybody has
that extra Pizzaz that razzled Dazzle
that makes what you say more important
than what other people say I first
realized I had the razzled Dazzle when I
was just about your age hey pencil dick
why don't you shut up and play as some
dudy season 2 oh for [__] sake where's
the Goddamn Dean he promised me this
[__] [__] wasn't going to happen you
know
what you can take your honorary PhD and
stick it up your ass I don't need this
and to everybody in this audience you
entitled little shits you picked the
wrong [__] career it's me Grier
penley and susten Thomas that's it we're
the only people getting paid to do this
and that's how we're going to [__]
keep it so tell Mommy and Daddy to move
the pelaton out of your old bedroom cuz
your moving back home holy [__] dude oh
BRZ is on BRZ is on one today I mean I I
was una aware that UCLA had a podcast
journalism school but no that that
that's o That's that's odd yeah maybe
the only one in the country even more
odd than uh the fact that brass venel
sounds exactly like George Lucas I would
love for at some point dudy to let us
know why why is that yeah I don't really
know I don't understand it at all but I
can't thank the Pod who was there in the
audience enough for his service now on
with the show a Halloween extravaganza
in four parts Part One a chill dude's
evening Stout part two Halloween croam
with Robert Dair Crow O Part three Short
Circuit City and part four your greatest
achievements and then after all of that
we're going to dig into our Halloween
candy bags and pull out a brand new
episode of dudy after dudy on dudy Plus
at patreon.com dudy where we'll see who
gets Brown today's episode champion and
gets to wear the belt for another
week probably you me hey whatever you
know what it's all good I'm bit of a
streak I'm uh he's on a bit of a streak
but uh as I said two weeks ago on our
show and sorry that we weren't around
last week I am the one in 31 and one and
in the words of Paul hymon Paul E
dangerously that's not a
prediction that's a spoiler but don't
worry about that the point is we're
having a good time here and uh I
mentioned I was uh I was at actually out
of town all week I was in uh Winnipeg
Manitoba Canada and it is the uh yeah I
was there for the Canada meeting it was
in Winnipeg this year oh cool dude yeah
who was there uh yeah yeah uh Justin
Trudeau of course was leading it Alis
Moret
Justin uh Michael bé bé had to be there
Eugene Levy Nathan meeting without bé no
it's not don't make fun of bé put some
respect on bublé's name you know when I
was what
bé you're not Michael boble you're not
pronouncing the accent at the
end um but I was uh I was over in
Winnipeg and uh you know I have I got to
tell you right now if you're if you're
if you're tuning in you know you you
will want to jump over to YouTube for
this I I hit dudes up um okay yeah
partway through my stay and I emailed
dudy I know this is something that uh
you're communicating with dudy outside
the show now you
have yes I have I'm surprised that you
why does it it's all right it's great
love it are and and I I may
have uh provided a little surprise a
little just a little something it's not
even it's just something I like to do
you know for the pods over the pal of
dudes
so we'll get to that we'll get to that
at some point you know maybe you know
somewhere in the middle it was my sort
of idea for dudy and I don't want you to
think that I'm you know that
I'm you know that I'm trying to I'm you
know I'm not I'm just I'm just I like
dud D I like dudy yeah me too yeah so
we're friends so I hit him up see here's
a thing for you will and Chad it's time
to celebrate the dudy dudes evening St
pre-sale is officially open right now
everybody can go to link tree.com dudy
and hit the dudes evening Stout link to
pre-order dudes evening Stout will and
Chad it's my pleasure to give you the
very first dudy dudes evening Stouts
brewed by Modest Brewing Company out of
astonishing Minneapolis Minnesota I want
you to enjoy them and I also want you to
enjoy a little jingle I came up with to
commemorate this occasion this is a
chill dudes evening Stout enjoy
a jingle uh I can't wait for the [__]
jingle dude but this is exciting this is
very exciting dude's evening Stout now
on pre-sale it's in our link tree yeah
and we have a we have a box here from
our wonderful Partners at modest Brewing
Company in Minneapolis Minnesota who are
the makers of and you know what you know
what's up they make this hey there's
this also you can get the dudy hard hard
Selter drink it down and you don't car
the thing um and also now we got this we
said is a box and I love it when we get
a box and we know what's in the when I
know what's in the I love it when I know
what's in the box you normally know it's
in the box and it's Priceless uh trading
cards but today we got this box let's
open the box and it has alcohol in it
which we get to drink some more
of oh [__]
dude evening CH dud evening Stout have a
CH dud evening that's what it's all
about spending time with friends on that
special day and when you meet a stranger
shake the hand and
say have a chill dud evening children's
evening
St that does sound like me that sounds
exactly like you that was [__] insane
that's incredible it's a pretty good
jingle too thanks D good jingle try to
get these
[__] yeah hey Chad you know what you're
really good I'll try and do it like
doozy did your
voice and in keeping with every
impression you've ever done it's simply
Robert loia hey kids enjoy your orange
juice nothing wrong with loia no I love
I love loia rest in peace did you know
that Robert loia has passed on I didn't
know that okay well what he'd be
about some people make it that way dude
uh we got these dudes evening Stouts and
uh I can't wait to all right we got a
[__] sorry for everybody L I got oh
damn we got a bunch of them too we got
eight Stouts eight dude's evening Stouts
and these are 75% alcohol is that right
yeah something like that oh
oo dude they're cool looking o [__] dude
yeah what do you think those are awesome
yeah look at that chill dudes evening
Stout there it is look there's the
there's the the logo man that's cool
have a chill dude's evening Stout it
says Barrel AED chocolate dipped
canoli Imperial Stout all right dude
you're ready cracking yours open hold on
here we go yeah here's I hope drinking
this doesn't erase my skeleton teeth
[__] got [__] all over Cheers Cheers
it's a chocolatey canoli treat I got
stuff on my [__] mic and
all
and we're playing the we're playing the
theme
[Music]
again
[__] that's why you
drink with that special day and when you
meet a stranger shake the hand and say I
want to shake your
hand have a children D's evening a
children's evening St how come it's not
okay well this is the
anyway andet strer a stranger shake
their hand and
say and then it's does that
whisper is it just play it again and
again it doesn't seem to be stopping um
at any rate going whatever who knows
dudy does what dudy does and de Works a
mysterious mysterious
ways this is the part where it just
rings out and it goes whisper
yeah it's
not well anyway okay so at any rate dud
chill dude's evening dude oh man it's
good [__] I'll tell you that right now
and we we're going to need to be careful
Chad because the last time a couple
weeks ago we tried the sample flavors M
we ended up going with um barrel-aged
chocolate dipped canoli Imperial Stout
and we got good and [__] ripped and
how much this is uh does that say
12.3% alcohol they're not skipping on
the Alcohol I'm death dude so one point
it don't
matter light me up I'm death dude oh
hold on brother dude that means I can
get as drunk as I want and it will not
kill me because I am dead yeah dude dude
well hold on dude I
remember one time Vince was like hey
dude we're going to change up your
gimmick dude we're going to call you
death Hogan brother you're going to come
to the ring and that way you'll be able
to defeat the Undertaker was that real
no [__] that wasn't real how am
I supp [__] do well because do have
you ever seen seems totally well he had
the the black and white you know the the
NW song is are you going to see the F ER
iron cannot wait to see the B
interesting I was curious about that cuz
I know you're a purist and you don't
like to watch H movies and stuff like
that I don't know if this to you was
different because it's not wrestlers in
the movie It's actors doing the movie
about wrestling precisely that's why
that's why that's that's fine I'm also
going to see the the one with Thor where
he's Hulk they're still making that what
there's Chris hemworth
[Music]
Hogan biop they're doing a Hulk some
kind of Hulk Hogan movie I don't know if
it's going to be like a cheeky
what the song is still going um yeah
that's interesting I didn't realize that
he was uh doing a h thing that's kind of
interesting I'll see that that I saw a
trailer for that ironclaw dude that [__]
looks good as
[__] Chad that's [__] disgusting I'm
death death don't
[Music]
burp song still going hey um yeah the
the Bon Eric story is quite sad and and
even though it's historical somewhat I
don't want to give it way uh to anyone
who might be going to see the movie cuz
I think you'll I think this movie is
going to be great I've seen nothing I've
only seen the trailer I will tell you
let me peel the onion a little bit and
get and tell you you know sort of my
thing as far as the business did you
know first of all did you know that I'm
a professional actor by
[Music]
trade I think I think I did hear that
somewhere yeah you might have read it in
the trades I read it in the trades dude
I read it in a daily variety it was just
article called Will Sasso professional
actor still professional actor yeah
there just an article about how yeah and
then it says uh I think the body of the
article is that he's a professional
actor by
[Music]
trade I forgot how much beer makes me
burp I really can't drink too much of
this we don't drink Chad and I both
don't for [__] sake
this oh Jesus hey I'll tell you a Funny
Story one time uh I was at my buddy
tomas's cabin right across the border uh
in Point Roberts what's called Point
Roberts cwn cab town they call it cab
Town USA it's an American peninsula look
it up on the on the Google and it is
it's
[Music]
essentially spend time friends on that
special day but you meet a stranger want
to shake your hand and
say yeah yeah
yeah [__] it's still going it's still
going I thought maybe that was the Ender
no it's not it's never going to end
point Roberts is a town cross dude take
it for me I'm death dude well that
doesn't surprise me that Chad's death
impersonation sounds just like Hulk
Hogan but also doesn't sound like Hulk
Hogan dude CU it's Chad impersonation
dude
um the the uh what was it okay so
there's a American Peninsula and some
people in my area around
Vancouver sometimes might have a cabin
or some sort of second home or something
over there my buddy uh Thomas Tomas
Tommy Tom he had uh you know to protect
the innocent cuz this story We his
grandma lived there she was out of town
so we went to her place uh which like
was cabin cabin like it was in the woods
and we got good and drunk and it was the
first time I got drunk on beer yeah and
I I was a late bloomer with the alcohol
in general I think I was 20 years old
and uh I got so [__] drunk it was
time to leave and I better I remember my
buddy uh Tom and and Thomas they were in
Tom's uh camper IED van the family had a
van and and I was drink
and I I threw up
Chad but this wasn't any kind of normal
uh vomit I I first the first thing they
did was like oh no sasso's going to puke
and they handed me a a Pringles tin an
empty Pringles Jesus yeah and I just
went and filled that up right away just
took that
long had enough control to go gave that
to another friend and then uh one of
them goes oh [__] what now what are we
going to give and they gave me a
lasagna I don't want to hear this a
lasagna pan just a deep dish lasagna pan
Jesus Christ and so then I had the
lasagna pan and I'm drunk and I had to
hold it still I had to keep it uh keep
it a toilet have toilet I couldn't stand
up and go I'm I'm over four bills at
this point we're talking about a 400
lb drunk as [__] on
beer 20-year-old will
wow filled this lasagna tan tan and then
I uh said oh I got to show the guys and
then I got up and went outside and there
was some steps and I fell down the
[__] steps thank God or I would have
brought the the tray of C into the um
into the van and when I got in the van I
remember that it was the camp rise van
cuz I ripped the the little kitchen
table you know right out of the floor of
the van you know uh my first time
getting
J was
about what's going on over there in
Texas uh my dad would give me beer
constantly as a sign of like manliness
remember once when I was maybe like 10
or something I used to love s live my
friends came over to watch it with me
spend of the night and my dad got us
both drunk that night come
on just got you pissed not piss but like
you know we were asleep 20 minutes in s
live yeah maybe it was just maybe it was
just U Charles Barkley episode my dad
used to [__] D to I'm having this
memory now that I haven't long time he I
would be in the tub like taking a bath
he would come in and just pour beer on
my
head you believe that [__] and he cuz he
was always like wash your hair with beer
it'll make
it well that's the part you remember but
that's just that's just his trick to so
that that's what you say in therapy but
I would call that let's just call it
child abuse yeah dude it was but so
funny to me now I don't know what else
to explain it have a chill dudes evening
chill dudes
evening on your boy
head poor some dude's even s on his head
this Thanksgiving oh
please poor some please put
that on the
internet um oh my gosh
song still going I know the [__]
song's still going hey dude's evening is
uh December 28th it's that special day
right in between Christmas you got plans
New Year's you got plans well in the
middle it's time for a chill dude's
evening you hang with your pals you
usually meet somewhere uh somewhere
local uh somewhere in the middle you
know
somewhere did you have that in Fox and
Hound it's like a in America anyway it's
like a chain kind of bar hang Place yeah
there's there's always the pig and
whistle the fox and H Hound the
[Music]
fox oh [__] it ended oh thank [__] well
Jesus it's
coming thank you moving on try not to
puke okay I'm putting this down right
now or there will be problems are you
going to hang out no I'll leave it here
in the CR
leave it in the crotch get it nice and
warm like any good stout should be uh
Hey appreciate you guys uh all the pods
and and everyone out there our wonderful
audience if you want some uh chill dudes
evening Stout it is available at uh well
you would just go to our link tree dudy
uh link tree.com dudy hit the hit the
[__] link dudy is in an astonishing
partnership with ag1 I'm looking for
whole body Health comprehensive
nutritional supplements but you know
what I don't want want I don't want that
stuff spread out over a bunch of
different supplements I don't know what
to take it becomes a whole mess now with
our wonderful sponsor ag1 I don't have
that problem it it's it's delicious and
I basically drink it every morning uh it
gives me an overall uh Wellness feeling
I'll tell you that much right now my
sleep is better I have better mental
Clarity my wonderful wife Molly is in on
it they even have these travel ones you
can get and they you know little packs
and [__] like that which is great
ag1 what I really dig about it is it's
all there in one scoop I like it by
itself you could just have it by itself
you can mix it into your favorite
protein shake or powder you take some of
this stuff leave it up to them okay
because it's a science-driven formula of
vitamins probiotics and Whole Food
sourced ingredients that's very
important ag1 is raising the standard
for quality in the supplement category
if you want to take ownership of your
health try ag1 and get a free one-year
supply of vitamin D and five free ag1
travel packs with your first purchase go
to drink a1.com
dudy that's drink a1.com
dudy check it
[Music]
out um Robert Deniro's love for
Halloween is legendary among the
Hollywood Elite he throws astonishing
balls every Halloween for his famous
friends costumes are mandatory and every
year he dresses as the same thing Jim
carries the mask you see Robert dairo
wanted that role very badly and he's
always been jealous of Jim Carrey so now
every Halloween he dresses up like the
mask and forces his friends to treat him
like the mask until sunrise then at
Sunrise he takes off the mask outfit and
writes five chrms I've supplied you guys
with the five from last year will you
know what comes next you blow my mind
this is Halloween chrom's with Robert
Dair Crow
begin okay I don't know about some of
that I don't know about any of that dude
I don't
think does dairo through big Hing
parties I don't know I don't know if he
does I'm positive he's not dressing as
the mask every year and forcing his
friends to treat him like the mask yeah
and I don't think that Jim Carry is his
Nemesis or that he was up for that role
yeah that's probably true at any rate we
got some chromes chromes love chromes
dude
[Music]
uh-huh it's like I'm watching killers of
the flower Moon all over again
go a flower mode I'm a bad
guy you know first of all you're going
to go do a movie professional actor by
trade do a movie because of flower Moon
movie to do Marty doing movie Marty
Leo but a bad guy
so you got after that you be a bad guy
be a
crow make it feel good all right here's
in my dudy folder here we got some
Halloween Halloween chrs some Robert
deir Crow chromes this first one is
called Richard
drus great okay uh thank you D for these
for these incredible chromes uh through
my Halloween party again this year Pizza
candy cocaine
beer Pacino came as a crow
solid guy knows what I like goino was a
noow spraying the ankle on a hike car
was there yeah guess not there sure
peshy had a little Cape said he was a
sexy vampire fell down got a scrape took
a piss in the
campfire Justin Timberlake puked Buster
pointex to two Elton John and rayon
Chong didn't know what to
do
somebody Bruce Springsteen played a song
dressed as a family guy everybody sang
along mostly drunk and high Leo was
dressed as
Jack Jack was dressed as Neo keano
Shrek Beck was dressed as
[Music]
Marino night was great till I got pushed
in the pool by a drunk Chucky doll named
Peter
oou wait a minute how long has Peter 's
been dead for some time okay I'm glad
that you know that Peter o is no longer
with us foot got wet had to get a new
sock went
inside found Richard dryish sucking his
own
[__] all
right that's some party that's some
Halloween party yeah that's did he say
what did or what dyus was dressed as we
didn't get
that I think he was sucking his own [__]
he was buy that was his Halloween
costume this one's called the crows
Halloween you never see a crow on
Halloween that's because they do a
different thing they go into the forest
sing A Chorus and cast a spell to become
a human
being they laugh human laughs and cry
human tears and if they like it enough
they can stay human for a year H I
didn't know that some crows like it so
much they never turn back they stay
human forever and make a new track some
stay for love some stay for money some
stay for drugs some stay to be
funny that's pretty funny joke it's
pretty good going to stay a human I was
a crown I'm a human some become doctors
some Drive tractors some become rock
stars some professional actors oh
[__]
are
you not all crows make good people
Charles Manson Ted Bundy and the guy who
made the Highlander
sequels okay they were allow all former
crows sure but most crows are better
than that taxpaying citizens and cute
little hats have a few kids join the PTA
make a few movies do a few plays from
everything I've said you must now surely
know from following This Thread that
you're talking to a crow oh [__] dairo
is a crow dairo is a crow well he also
said professional actor are you a
crow I'm I think we're all I think we
all got a little crow in us the Raven is
the mimic the trickster yeah you know
and of course the crow is from The Raven
family so sure uh this one's called the
trick and the treat okay I meet a lot of
dads tell me they like my m movies quote
a few lines let them squeeze my
boobies what hang out with him on
weekends watch a few games do heroin in
their bathrooms forget their
names see them again in a grocery store
buying milk with the kids I'm buying I'm
buying condoms with a
[__] what see him again in the grocery
store buy milk with their kids I'm
buying condoms with a [__]
cuz it's the day before Halloween that's
my tradition drugs and prostitutes take
a [__] in your
kitchen what is he doing dress up as the
Scream ghost the very next night trick
or treat [__] it's time for a
fight he's very violent this Theo this
one is called basic Ashley Halloween
okay my wife takes me to the pumpkin
patch every [__]
year yeah it's said it I guess yeah
clearly we wear beige sweaters and white
brim hats that goofy Instagram gear
photo after photo drinking pumpkin spice
she says you're always frowning th face
that's
nice I hate it I hate it hear it smells
like [__] why why do we take these pics
just so you can post them online like
I'm some basic
[__] women love the fall and all the
heavy clothes it's hot outside let's go
home I don't know how to
pose but she won't let me
leave we need the perfect shot so she
can show her Facebook friends they're
the only friends she's got
oh damn the pumpkin patch will soon be
closed all the Ashley's dragged their
men away to the mall to buy more beige
clothes for a Thanksgiving photo shoot
the very next
day he's very against social media yeah
well I understand those pictures you
know the pictures fall rolls around and
everyone's like date night with this guy
on social media and it's and they're
always in the the wide brim hat they got
the usually a baggy white sweater the
brown leather boots up to the we've all
seen the the the memes you like memes
what is it
Mimi I'm a professional actor by trade
okay here's the last one this is called
express yourself I like the Madonna song
A that's one of my favorite Madonna
songs me too you got to make him take
pictures in a pumpkin patch hey hey hey
hey okay um it's okay Express Yourself
express
yourself it's Bor the
door okay here it goes I'm jealous of
kids they get the trick-or treat put on
costumes and wigs more candy than you
can eat that's why this Halloween first
time since 68 I'm going
trick-or-treating with Madonna as my
date wait that's from last year I guess
they went trick-or-treating together
okay we know where the rich people live
they give out full-size candy bars we'll
drink hard liquor get aggressive throw
eggs at fancy
cars H Madonna will get sad because we
are old I'll have to cheer her up remind
her of all the good times we had and
offer her a peanut butter
cup what didn't quite rhyme uh then will
toilet paper shar's house to make Momo
feel better Sher talked [__] about her
on TV back in 198 whatever I don't know
okay we'll crash some Halloween parties
at the Frat houses UCLA make Tick Tock
with college girls Madonna will decide
to
stay she likes younger people you know
yeah yeah okay uh and what costume did
we wear a princess and a crow our
costumes Were Meant to scare we went as
madana and Robert
daero
nice they didn't even wear costumes or
did they well it's like lulio C did he
go as Madonna and she won as dairo that
was not established you're absolutely
right could have been I pretty good man
Madonna with the con TTS I got the con
TTS long blond ponytail truth to DARE
style course it on outside was a good
riding around on on a stage je Paul G je
Paul
jeul
J jum anyway there it is
[Music]
thank you moving
on that good
dude yep good [__] man this stuff is
interesting this is interesting well I'm
speechless oh except to say that all
dudy apparel and accessories can now be
found at dudy store.com and there are
some brand new dudy logo t-shirts
they're simple elegant classy and
they'll be the only shirts allowed in
AMC theaters starting Christmas 2025 and
of course you can pick up a good job
boner mug to put your liquids coins or
pens in and speaking of liquids coins
and pens will you recently took a trip
to Canada and you were nice enough to
make a video about your trip and share
it with me so I'm going to share it with
everybody else Chad you're gonna love it
will can you please intro what we're
about to see here I absolutely will d i
was uh as I said at the beginning of the
show uh I was in Canada I was in
Winnipeg Canada and I decided to make a
little Vlog uh just to you know let
y'all know what I was up to or just you
know for a little bit of fun it's fun
we're supposed to have a a good time
yeah dude no I'm I'm down with this I
think it's great and so you then emailed
it to doy I did I did I did something
that I don't normally do and that's
because of my own reasons but uh I don't
want to your own reason well I you know
I Reas it's like I say at the beginning
of every show it's like hey the dudy
does dudy thing we are dudy we we're two
dudes [__] around and sometimes I
keep it uh keep it separate but I felt
uh I wanted to reach out and do this
thing and make this Vlog so take it away
will thanks Free Will and handsome chat
well here I am in Winnipeg it's the
Gateway to the West so you know I
figured tonight why not go out and have
a Winnipeg night alone here in Winnipeg
uh so that's that's what the Vlog is
that's a b night dude be cuz I'm going
to go Mastermind explanatory here and oh
hold on dude let me tell you what to
Vlog look how [__] up my eyes are it's
dry out here this happens every time I'm
in the middle of Canada God use
lotion oh the [__] Al hat yeah I got
the AL hat this is
[Music]
great got a very affordable uh ticket on
a ticket app to the Manitoba moose game
they're hosting the Iowa wild so let's
go check that out we going to the hockey
game oh hockey of course I was like what
the [__] is the Iowa
wild oh
no in the s b e Here Comes zambon
guy zambon
guy love zambon
Guy this is how the players get ready
for the game yeah these are the
that guy is terrible yeah yeah they both
suck if you're just listening that's uh
some cornhole they're playing cornhole
in The Concourse oh man went on for a
while no zero points and no zero this is
uh my favorite Canadian steak chain he
the [__] is this [__] [__] that up
thank you for dining with us will bring
that belt home thank you
Cameron you know something I really
enjoy doing whenever I'm back home in
Canada is walking around reading signs
in my Canadian
accent Hamilton building good local
everything good everything local sport
Manitoba qualo Training Center deer plus
almond [__] Burton Cummings theater
eh
Giant Tiger Jagged Little Pill scoa
Bank [__] Mark and Dilly in the
morning
Crow ashown Market ATM groceries canab
what so it's a convenience store but you
also sell weed yep all right take it
easy
Bud s's breakfast special is back oh
Jesus dude this guy rules
Intrepid explorator on
Instagram guy was weird oh man well
there it is that was uh that was uh what
do you think I mean I've seen some
Billboards uh driving through town of
killers of the flower Moon and a lot of
them say simply Masterpiece I would say
this is a true Masterpiece thank you my
friend that's very sweet of you that was
[__] hilarious and I think it
actually gives you a pretty good
representation of Winnipeg yeah uh
Winnipeg Manitoba it is the Gateway uh
to the West we went I went to the game I
went to dinner by myself at high
steakhous they really [__] the steak
up I asked for a Chicago style did you
see that steak no you didn't even look
at the corpse no I I zero doubt yeah
well it was it was all burned whatever I
shouldn't put them on [__] blast but
they shouldn't have put my steak on
blast hey I asked for Chicago style not
Winnipeg
Style well sincerely the video meant a
lot thank you for doing that it was
really
great you're you absolutely D that's
very nice little you know very nice I
don't know I'm what that was very nice
feel like I should have made a video
don't it's all right feel like I should
have gone to Winnipeg feel like I should
have went to the hockey game and made a
video about it no it's all right hey
look it's this is see this is what I
mean and I'm not trying to get we're in
the middle of the show I don't want to
[__] slow down the show we're having
a good show by the way Chad just between
me yeah you're having a good show yeah
you are too dude yeah let's let's have a
good show we are both having a good show
they can't hear us right now it's just
you and me let's have a good show I'm
down I agree okay well uh uh you guys
that was uh that was uh that was the
thing thanks for tuning in uh today's
episode and if you are enjoying today's
episode please uh subscribe to YouTube
uh We've crossed 60,000 followers even
if you only listen on the podcast apps
go over to YouTube give us a follow uh
uh subscribe on YouTube We would
appreciate that that'll help us grow
this thing uh hit the notifications Bell
so you know that we uh you know when we
put out new [__] uh we also have the
damn Clips Channel now uh dudy Clips the
best way to get to it because there's
all sorts of uh action online there is
to go to our link tree.com uh link
tree.com
dudy and hit the clips Channel there we
got so much stuff going on on Instagram
@ dudy pod show such crazy [__] our our
old pal freak arama made a fun video
that video game one yeah there's a video
game video on on um Instagram go check
that out there stuff on Facebook we're
on Tik Tok with all sorts of clips and
thank you so much to everyone who is on
dudy plus that's our patreon we call it
dudy plus
patreon.com dudy and if you are enjoying
the program and you would like to get
more dudy we got dudy Plus there's all
sorts of weird [__] watch alongs we
got one coming up very soon uh all sorts
of weird flavor like that uh some of the
weirdest [__] we recently watched um
waiting to die a pilot that you and I
wrote and produced over at CBS and uh
there's all sorts of movies and weird
watch along [__] and a brand new episode
of dudy after dudy you're going to get
more dudy and it gets a little goes a
little off the rails it really is truly
us up to us dudy after dudy uh after
every episode of dudy seven bucks a
month uh gets you that please there's
also a video of Richard dfus sucking his
own [__] you can find that on on patreon
right
now you're going to have to really
search for it let us know if you find it
yeah it's buried very deep in the the
mountain of other material but it is
there please share the Show online with
everyone that you think might enjoy the
program or follow Chad Chad follow
Chad's light suggestion of forcing
everyone you know to consume the show
now is a good time you know what dude
I'm starting to think there may be a
different strategy here what you do is
you leave dudy on you watch dudy and
then when somebody walks in who's like
hey what are you doing quickly shut your
computer turn off the TV and be like
nothing I'm not doing anything I was not
watching anything and whatever I was
watching is not for you you cannot see
what I'm watching this isn't for you and
then make a whole thing of it for about
a day yeah and then do you tell them
okay you can check it out or just keep
it just leave
Clues yeah leave Clues leave a can of
dudy hard hard Seltzer just leave QR
codes the house yeah QR codes that's a
good way to do it actually you can get
QR codes if you go to Pal a dudy our pal
Cody who's one of our incredible pods
pal dudy make stickers they're all over
my [__] bottle here and you can go
and you can get the same damn stickers
and some of them have uh QR codes I
think he throws those in at any rate now
is a good time for you to pause the
program and go off and do all of those
things and you know set all those
notifications subscribe on on thing and
YouTube stagram Instagram YouTube and
all that [__] and uh we'll take a moment
here to let you do that we'll be right
back welcome
back uh also if you want a guest on a
podcast and it's a podcast that you host
you can have me be that guest all you
got to do is send an email to book Chad
coach gmail.com I answer them in the
order received I do three per week it's
every Saturday from 10:00 a.m. to 11:00
a.m. PST and 20 minute increments and uh
I've been having a blast doing those
love hanging out with the pod seeing
what their podcasts are all about again
I answer them in the order received so
right now there's about a 5 Monon
backlog but do that getting through hey
double fisting you like double fisting
used to dude my youth well I did some
double fisting back when I puked all
over the place at my buddy tomas's
Grandma's cabin holy [__] did that get
messy I'll talk a little bit more about
vomiting all over the place and some of
the stuff that I broke holy [__] that I
just break everything when I was a drunk
guy in mys because I'm large even when I
lost lb from 1999 to 2000 that just
meant that I was more limble limber I
went from 450 to 250 I'll tell you a
story about breaking all sorts of [__]
when I was uh when I was a big beefy
20-year-old who had just lost 200 lbs
and was so excited to be able to run
faster jump higher and break more [__]
nice dude at any rate uh let's read some
um some YouTube
com what you were like wanyama oh
wanyama you like the wanyama [__] yeah
dude yeah man he's already do [__]
that's like yeah super human basically
the uh the Spurs number one draft pick
is how how tall is the boy how how big
is this guy 9 foot2 he's and he's like a
kid right he's like 19 or some [__] 12
he's 12 years old he's 12 years old and
he is he's [__] incredible yeah is he
he's he's up over two bills though he's
73 uh he's 74 I think and I think he
weighs like 210 lb or something anyway
he's a [__] Phenom and he's I don't I
I he he's got an outside game he's got a
mid-range game he can drop threes he can
[__] drive the lane he's a rebound
machine he'll smack your [__] out of
Dodge if you come in through there and
he's literally kick that will just
[__] put you on the ground a what
straight kick a straight kick yeah he
should do a Sweet Chin Music you know
I'd love to get if I was web yama's side
I'd hit the Sweet Chin Music you know
what that is no it's not really Shan
Michaels I I'll do some newer here let's
do we should have newer uh newer
wrestling
impersonations sure D Bret Hart we love
that dog he doesn't say that to Bret
Hart anyway okay let's read some YouTube
comments we got YouTube comments here uh
these comments are from last week's
little minisode where basically we
watched uh a clip mhm that ended up on
our Clips Channel um uh uh and that's
what we had last week so these comments
are from that of course like I said
link.com dudy hit the clips channel uh
thingy and we got brand new clips
dropping all the time a lot of old
school classic dudy Clips I know dude
infomania Stone Cold Steve Austin reads
will sasso's childhood diary all the Tom
hanne movies are showing up in the clips
Channel it was only a year and a half
ago but you can see at least uh for me I
feel like I can see a drastic difference
in how young I look
really yeah okay that's interesting all
right I've been uh 40 years old since I
was 16 uh now I'm 48 okay this one is
from alus brondo Al alus brondo
996 uh he says I'm a full-time Uber
driver in a Tesla he says in parenthesis
needs us to know that if you're looking
for an Uber driver uh this guy has a
Tesla and I'm blazing through the back
catalog and I found myself calling
everyone dude brother buddy and pal and
so on this is the funniest show I've
seen in years I want to shake your hand
thank you alluce brondo 996 that's what
it's all about this is from thing
Fitzpatrick who says it's pretty cool to
hear how much dudy speech has evolved
over the past year plus Chad what do you
think of that totally agree yeah and I
think I mean I don't know exactly what
is dudy voice but it definitely has
gotten more human sounding even the
words that it uses is it's less robotic
uh yeah it's fascinating and I think as
AI technology progresses it's going to
get even crazier sure sure but like I
like to say dudy is the most sensient AI
I've ever witnessed on any platform at
all across all this weird AI [__] that's
happening and what I like about it is
that I do feel like I'm more friendly
with D I do feel like d
is more and more human all the time I'm
very excited to see where that goes but
you know I love I I'll whatever M I I I
want I want you to know the same way
that I want dudy to know that and I'm
not talking about emailing dudy and all
that [__] I'm just saying I enjoy
doing this show more than anything and
this is uh this is a fun thing that fing
Fitzpatrick has has pointed out it's
something that I didn't even realize I'm
realizing it now it has made me closer
to dudy which is a but also lovely this
is from Michael Gonzalez 6314 says great
idea to create the dudy clips Channel
dudy I could never find my favorite Tom
Hayne Clips to show my friends before so
there you go thank you for uh sending
those in uh please feel free to leave
the comments everywhere as D says D's
always reading always collecting that
data so anytime you're writing something
you know not only Chad and I are reading
it D's getting into it and then we might
be you might somehow see it coming
fruition Circuit City is back in
business as an online retailer and word
on the street is they're looking to
partner with a streaming service to
produce a sitcom using their brand will
and Chad you got to crack this one
here's what I know they want so far has
to have Charlie Sheen has to have Johnny
5 from short circuit has to have
something to do with Circuit City come
on guys let's land this ship this is
Short Circuit City begin all right [__]
we could do this yeah did you know the
circuit City's back in business no I
didn't know that what really yeah dude
there are a website only now online
retailer there's one uh near here in Los
Angeles uh on Sunset Boulevard there's a
[__] old Circuit City wait where it's
over like it's over it's near um the the
[__] Sunset Junction it's there's a
Circuit City it's near at Del Taco and I
used to go that used to be my thing I'd
go and pick up this cap 5 cable or
something you know cuz we're we're
having a land party playing some Halo
back in the day right over here and then
I go over to Del Taco you know what I
like to Taco the [__] what go ahead
what do you think I
liked something chicken bean and rice I
liked the uh french fries oh the Del
Taco french fries for some reason cuz
they came in a [__] like 32 o cup
fatk okay so we got to figure this out
it's called Short Circuit City it has to
have Charlie Sheen and Johnny five from
short circuit now this is have something
to do with Circuit City obvious and it
has to do have to do something with
Circuit City okay we're going to come up
with this show for Charlie Sheen another
vehicle for Charlie Sheen here's the
interesting thing though uh not too long
ago here on the program we did um uh
standard psychological evaluation oh
yeah which is nothing uh like a standard
psychological
evaluation oh the dudy Stout
Chad look yeah we can't tell you're
wearing uh Grim Reaper makeup might have
been you people are listening head over
to YouTube watch Chad burp um on the
standard psychological evaluation it did
show us a picture of short circuit
because Steve Gutenberg was in it right
and now dudy wants a short circuit based
TV show with Charlie Sheen and Johnny 5
all right here's what I'm getting
Charlie Sheen is the manager of a brick
and mortar Circuit City let's just we
can we can do that easily okay I think
in some way he fled a a family who owned
a mom and pop shot circuit store and
Char was like [__] you dad I don't want
to work in your little circuit store I'm
working at [__] Circuit City and so
he [__] off when he was 18 he moved
out of the dad's house and did not uh go
do the family business and so in
Revenge that Dad built a new son and
that new son is Johnny 5 who works in
the mom and pop circuit store
wait okay yeah first of all I love that
that's what's up it's like when my when
I went to college my parents replaced me
with a chihuahua named Rudy oh and if
you've checked out some dudes after dudy
you know what the fate of Rudy was
I tell I'm the Grim Reaper and Rudy died
Rudy dad oh man we're gonna I we might
have to tell that story in dudy after
dudy happened with Tommy not and I'm not
uh you know protecting the innocent here
with the names Tommy blotcher yeah uh
and me and Marshall joint compound cook
and Cyrus D after dud I'm happy to do
legit Health point my point is this yeah
can we also fold in I love that yes can
we also fold in there that Charlie
Sheen's dad uh poured beer on his head
while he was in the bathroom then that's
why he left yeah yeah he poured beer
[__] you Dad you thought was that was
child abuse you I don't know what's
happening to the impersonation at this
point maybe a little St to the brain but
look just call it what it is yeah
Caitlyn Jenner Jesus Christ it's like
Dad you don't understand pouring beer on
my head in the bathtub really [__] me
up now I'm never going to work in your
[__] store and I don't even want your
last name so [__] off my new name is
Johnny Circuit City and who's the dad
how about we've done David Letterman is
the dad yeah that's right the uh the
Burlington C Factory one he was a GH we
did oh his father-in-law potential
father-in-law was Liam Liam
n if this is going to be can this be
this is going to be like a sitcom sitcom
like kind of like alen thick [__]
love that dude alen thick he was he
wasn't at the he wasn't at the Winnipeg
meeting do you know why no the meeting
in Canada because he has passed on did
you know that is he really [__] dead
this [__] guy I kill so many I can't
keep track he's death uh yeah yeah
[__] dude I didn't realize that yeah
so he's um so hey maybe the the the
we'll use AI technology to make Charlie
Sheen a little younger so it's a 90s a
90s style thing yeah for some reason
we'll make Allan thick a little older
just for the [__] of it cuz he's got to
be and uh you know Charlie Sheen in his
20s or something like that and Johnny 5
uh it can do all the 90s tropes because
we said it back in the 90s and Ellen
think's like [__] you're going to go
off and start why don't you come back
and work for your mom and pop uh store
here with your son with your brother
Johnny number five that's not my [__]
brother dad that's a bucket of bolts you
[__] put together with hot glue and
Scotch tape you expect me to call it my
brother you watch your [__] mouth you
[__] flip toid and is like but I am
alive I am your brother and then what
love interest or no the they it's
basically it's so it's Charlie Sheen
Caitlyn Jenner M um uh starting a brick
and mortar Circuit City maybe it's the
first maybe because it's in the 90s it's
the First Circuit City or who knows how
long that Circuit City is maybe at its
height and basically what winds up
happening we can fold in another
character who's the CEO of Circuit City
that wants Charlie Sheen to get that
store so big it destroys his father's
store I like that so they can buy him
out and that can be Robert loia yeah
yeah listen Charlie we need you to get
this Circuit City so big that your
father's store has to [__] close down
yeah we hey Robert losia wants you to
start a Circuit City that's going to put
your mom and pop show store out of
business but one thing Robert loia
doesn't know even though we were College
roommates and very old we're both dead
what well we're in college roommates
okay and uh he you know what something
that Circuit City CEO Robert loia
doesn't understand is how to is how to
operate he doesn't even under understand
how to operate a a flip toid capacitor
and the flip toid capacitor is what made
Johnny number five sent it the flip toid
capacitor the flip toid capacitor that's
his secret thing that ien think is mag
secret engineering project all right
well I don't know
uh that's legit dude I can see that as a
sitcom yeah and from there who the [__]
knows um um yeah I don't know I don't
know sounds like a good show I would
already watch watch it Johnny number
five oh and then uh they both um how
about um then how about uh Johnny number
five uh what if Charlie Sheen uh
befriends Johnny number five and Charlie
Sheen's a big basketball fan and then he
makes he changes his arms and legs and
makes him Victor web web Yama height and
then they both but he has to go with him
to uh the 1992 dream team uh game in
Barcelona and they both end on the Dream
Team they can replace Christian leer and
just Christian leer he was the only one
who didn't belong on the Dream Team and
then shots Firs he still alive leer yeah
no oh yeah yes and uh I hope so and then
and then uh they go to they travel to
Barcelona for the Olympics and Jesus
Charlie Sheen is the only one who knows
how to use a flip toid uh capacitor so
that he can help Johnny 5 and and they
win the Olympics and then him and uh
Michael Jordan uh start have a have a
weedies deal did it nailed it that was
pretty good dude
yep your whole season Arc is to the
Barcelona Olympics yeah that first
season going all the way to the Olympics
love
that thank you moving on no thank you D
oh see you did there yeah all right will
and Chad you've both spent your entire
professional careers in the
entertainment industry
I'm curious to hear what you each think
are your greatest achievements now that
you're middle-aged it's okay to be
serious in this one I really want to
know thanks guys this is your greatest
achievements I'm all ears interesting
interesting um I have not spent my
entire professional career in the
entertainment industry the first maybe
like seven six or seven years out of
college was trying to break in having
like shitty kind of peripheral jobs out
here in LA but that said I I don't know
dude my it's it's interesting cuz like
how do you even gauge what is your your
greatest achievement to me the things
that I'm like most proud of are things
where I was able to kind of like use the
weird art that I make to [__] with some
system in place uh like you do a fair
amount of that in my opinion that that
that attitude at least is in a lot of
the things that you've done uh
professionally yeah the attitude is but
I mean like if you're making a sitcom
for [__] CBS like I am proud of
waiting to die which we made that's just
kind of a straight sitcom there's no uh
like interesting things in there that is
commenting on systems at large but like
when I was in college for example I used
to write these weird things they would
just be like little short stories or
manifestos or whatever then I would run
off 10,000 copies of these things in the
film School copy room and I would insert
them into I would I would follow the
people around in the morning who would
put the like school newspapers at USC in
the little boxes and I would insert
these things into every one of those
newspapers then I'd go to like a 300
person lecture class and just sit in the
back and watch everybody open these
newspapers and be like what the [__] is
this some people would read it some
people would laugh most people just
throw it on the [__] ground but to me
that was kind of like the beginning of
being like oh here's this dumb system
where I can make free copies in my film
school class and I could put them in
these [__] newspapers and so I did
that that's really interesting you I've
seen you do all sorts of weird things
that you were doing some [__] well you I
mean this has done all sorts of [__]
he's written all these you know movies
TVs and uh TV shows and books movies TVs
books yeah street art I I feel like
street art is primarily like [__]
with the system dude you did weren't you
planning to do a a a some sort of
painting apparatus on a drone dude that
I [__] found two guys who were in
UCLA School of Engineering this is like
[__] 10 years ago probably and I just
I was like I'll pay you guys a little
bit of money to do some R&D to try and
build me a drone that I can just upload
a [__] piece of art and it will spray
paint that art on the side of building
and it wound up going nowhere but I
still would love to do that but I think
probably the the achievement that I
think is the most interesting I will say
and therefore potentially my greatest is
I wrote a book called strange animals
this is probably 10 years ago is um the
premise of the book is a woman becomes
pregnant and she decides
to uh remain pregnant and then issue an
anonymous kind of challenge to the
American right saying if you really are
pro-life here's the deal I'm currently
pregnant and I'm looking for a $100
million if I get that in a bank account
in donations I will have the baby give
it up for adoption and then put all that
money in a trust fund for the kid if I
get a penny less I refund all the money
and have an abortion put your money
where your mouth is basically that was
the premise of that
book I remember this to try and Market
the book I I created like a website as
though it was the main character of my
book having written that
and it the whole idea was like it would
gain traction and then my publisher
would come in and kind of like dump
gasoline on the fire that I'm creating
to get me on you know interviews and
whatever and so I did my part I put it
out there people got outraged and there
were it was covered in like Vice I think
covered at Fox News was covering it and
then right at the point I needed my
publisher to step in to get me like big
mainstream coverage they just [__]
cut the cord they were like [__] you
we're out because they got very scared
of it you know but um I would imagine so
yeah I that to me is like other than I
had one book get turned into a movie so
I got to see characters like come to
life on a screen but seeing this
character that I created in that book
kind of come to life on the internet was
always just like fascinating to me
that's really cool that's like that's
that's an incredible achievement looking
at things in a very unique way and
you've also I mean you did you've you've
create like we were talking about we did
a thing together but you also did uh you
create a bad judge yeah I got a show on
network TV uh for a season that was an
interesting experience for sure
mhm uh that's good [__] what do you got
dude well you know I don't know I I sort
of think I sort of I have some I think
about this a lot I think about this a
lot I don't want to bore everybody with
you know professional stuff but dudes he
said you know that that's what we're
doing and uh I am a professional actor
by trade Chad did you know that yes okay
so um I just still look I've been
fortunate enough to be doing it since I
was you know 15 I was a teenager I was
there was work to uh there was stuff
shooting in Vancouver you were the web
Yama of professional act web Yama of fat
little teenagers and um and uh I uh so
I've been I have been fortunate enough
to do stuff that I look back at with uh
such fond memories of things like I did
this show in Canada called Madison that
was about these uh you know it was like
it was like a Degrassi kind of show that
sort of thing um was about these kids um
in in in Vancouver and uh it was all
over the country and it played
internationally played everywhere but
the States you know it was in all other
bunch of other englishspeaking countries
and when I think of [__] like that you
know because an actor uh you know actors
we say this and this this crosses over
to all sorts of careers and [__] is
you're only as good as your last job
right whatever you're doing uh you're
holding yourself to a standard and
you're only as good as your last job I
bring that up to say that you know
I look back at at a show like Madison
and go man that was [__] so much fun
and I'm so fortunate that I got to work
with these talented young people at that
time we were all in our late teens and
early 20s and I was a teen I was 17 when
I started doing that show and uh and you
know and I you know really learned so
much about acting from my peers on that
show and to go from that I did that for
5 years and then a little bit later I
ended up on Mad TV which is you know
that's kind of I I love Mad TV so much I
love it so much I love the experience I
love my comedy sketch comedy siblings as
I like to call them that we came
together and make that show and the
incredible writers and producers and
everybody that worked behind the scenes
the hair and makeup wardrobe were
incredible and on Down the Line whatever
I've gotten to do all these fun things
and things that I'm very proud of and
whatever right like I really am
but I'm looking at this through that
scope of like you're only as good as
your last thing you're only as good as
your last thing and if I am being
serious I do feel like like I get on
myself I was sort of talking about this
on one of the other episodes just I'm
just talking artistically I kind of get
on myself for underestimating things MH
you know sure like I sort of go like
well what's gonna happen with this like
I even thought Mad TV because I joined
in the third season the show had two
successful Seasons then half the class
half the cast was cleaned out and um I
ended up uh in the show on the third
season and I was like this [__] thing
isn't going to work anymore it's going
to be over I better get some good
uh some good tape for my for my um demo
reel and I sort of felt that way about
the show for a while but at the same
time
really working as hard as I could to
make this thing great I want it to be
incredible I wanted to work really hard
I worked really hard all the all this
all the silly stuff that we did I was so
passionate about it is the word I should
use it's not it's it's the kind of work
that isn't work it's a ton of fun but I
was
extremely passionate about it and in
spite of myself being sort of
underestimating things then you go off
at after Mad TV do you do a bunch of TV
pilots and some movies and things and
again I've been so far I've been so
fortunate I would look at I I look at it
this way here's here's what I want to
say two things number one being in this
business that I get to do is is my is my
you know I don't I don't want to say my
greatest achievement I don't want to get
all whatever I think you know what I
mean but it is it is that that's part
one is that yeah
even just getting to do this you know I
get I'm so blown away that I've gotten
to do this sort of thing and and
hopefully make some people laugh or
entertain some people along the way uh I
love what I do I love I love acting and
I love silly make them ups and doing all
the comedy [__] that I get to do and all
this fun stuff
that's an achievement that I just I'm
I'm I'm I'm of that mind and I'm being
serious now that I just sort of
I don't know what it is maybe it's my
Canadian thing you know we were we were
talking about this at the Canada meeting
in Winnipeg yeah Alan Thick went on
about it forever yeah he came in um via
satellite uh from the other
um that alone is it's I I feel like
that's an incredible achievement but I
do have this attitude about it of keep
going what's the next thing what's the
next thing this brings me to my second
point I I feel
like
I'm ready for Point number two oh I'm
sorry oh I'm sorry I oh I'm so sorry
I've taken too long to talk about my
thing the dudes he said talk seriously
I'm just laughing dude well I was
laughing dude um here's my second point
and this will only take about 15 to 20
minutes for me to get
through
okay when I look at things in
in a linear sense and you know that time
exists right Chad hell no dude I mean
come on but as far as humans
understanding time and the the the small
amount of time that we get to spend on
this planet and how fortunate I feel and
proud I am of of of the work that I've
gotten to do when I put that sort of
linear time thing in there and I go
you're only as good as your last thing
it reminds me to be in the now it
reminds me not to be as a younger man to
underestimate things just cuz you got
like some weird low self-esteem um even
though you're you're you're you know the
fantasy of it I get to go out and and do
silly [__] I love doing that that's
always been my passion and I feel like
when I was a little kid it was like to
make a pretend place and whether you're
doing that in art music whatever kind of
craft you're doing whatever makes you
proud of living your life and keeps you
coming back then next day you know these
are the things that keep us going and am
I hiding in it or am I celebrating life
through it I don't know necessarily
that's something like maybe I'm not wise
enough to figure that out but what I do
know is that right now at this point and
the way I feel about it dudy is my
greatest achievement oh [__] I really
feel that way because I because I feel
like this show that I love to do I love
working with my pal Chow dudy handshake
and and I love that we get to have my
little here with us and I love D I've
talked about it it and I truly feel that
now I truly feel like like I get to come
here and and and hang out with all of
the pods pal dud and and really truly
just crack wise and [__] around I'm so
stoked that we get to do it and that's
what's up it's my greatest
achievement argue thank you moving on
just how I
feel yeah dudes you wanted us to be
serious whatever it's not serious what a
goddamned episode guys you blew episode
79 out of the water you got 100 points
no ifs ANS or butts that brings your
cumulative score to
7,444 so you only have
2556 more points before you hit that
first goal the big 10K we're getting
closer dude okay remember that one week
where I asked you to take three photos
well this week I want you both to go
through all of your photos and next week
each of you bring in your favorite three
photos that you've ever taken thanks to
everyone for joining us this week have a
happy Halloween and until next week call
me
dudy
d
d yeah yeah yeah
have a chill dudes evening you see chill
dudes evening Stout that's where that
that would make that that's that I see
that's how you would have done it well
hold on dude that's music
brother anyway hey welcome to dudy after
dudy you can find it on dudy Plus at
patreon.com dudy we're going to have a a
good oldfashioned dudy after dudy time
we're going to chill we're we got you
know it's We're Half corked because of
this D see Stout neither one of us drink
in two episodes now we had seems like we
both do now D beer I can't do that
anyway they got us oh man oh boy so it's
going to be an interesting one you know
the deal dudy after dudy is just kind of
a chill hang hey the mood's a little
more mellow in here and [__] [__] it
it's GNA be a good
one welcome to dudy after dudy the
flagship weekly show of dudy plus you
can join us at patreon.com dudy I don't
even know how to calculating this one
guys I think I'm going to have to
develop another system just to help me
figure this out so I'm going to go get
started on that you boys relax you
deserve it after what you delivered
today this is dudy after dudy have fun
guys cheers D sounds good all right dude
what uh we brought up in the main
episode The Story of Rudy died oh yeah
that's right and so I was going to tell
this story which is essentially the
origin story of a prank call that has
become
a a slogan an inside joke something that
constantly is repeated in our group of
friends yeah it it sure is do you know
actually that I have that
call what I have that prank call on my
computer I mean we got to listen to that
oh we're going to listen to
it tell a friend then R
review if you like d here's what you do
please tell a friend
then if you like
d please tell friend then